LOKI
We have a saying in Asgard.
Where there are wolf's ears,
wolf's teeth are near.
It's a trap.
MOBIUS
He's lying. Just playing games.
You had me for
a second, Loki. My ears are sharp too.
♪♪
MOBIUS
Here's the deal.
Fugitive variant has been
killing our Minutemen.
We haven't been able to find him,
so let's bring in an expert.
LOKI
That's me.
MOBIUS
The criminal could be anywhere, anytime.
We gotta be careful.
Anything we do can
impact the course of history.
Do you get that?
Loki! Loki!
[Volcano explodes]
LOKI
Right on cue!
♪♪
JUDGE RENSLAYER
The timekeepers are monitoring
every aspect of this case.
Trusting this man
is not a good idea.
LOKI
No one bad is ever truly bad.
And no one good is ever truly good.
SYLVIE
This isn't about you.
LOKI
Right.
MOBIUS
Loki, wait!
♪♪
MOBIUS
I believe, stupidly...
...you can be whatever you
want to be, even someone good.
LOKI
By the way, I should have
an equal amount of security.
This is insulting.
MOBIUS
You just can't help yourself.